[Musique]
bonsoir c'est lors d'auditions publiques
sur et c'était unique sénat avec le
figaro en direct évidemment pendant une
heure comme tous les lundis
ils ont été les héros les premières
lignes depuis trois mois ce sont les
personnels hospitaliers qui ont eu droit
aux applaudissements à 20 heures chaque
soir depuis ça s'est un peu estompée il
faut bien le dire mais ils attendent
beaucoup du plan santé qui commencent à
être discuté aujourd'hui et dont les
parlementaires devraient débattre à
partir de la mi juillet on va parler de
tout ça avec vous damien abad bonsoir
vous êtes mensualités ce soir vous êtes
président du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale député de l'ain on
va parler du second tour des municipales
aussi c'est de 28 juin maintenant c'est
sûr ou presque sauf contre-indication
éventuellement vers le 10 juin la droite
peut-être bénéficier des situations se
posera la question
et puis dans un instant brigitte boucher
est à mme tran huy des chaînes
parlementaires seront sur le plateau
pour vous poser des questions
puis vous serez en débat avec deux
parlementaires marie le bec qui est
député la république en marche et cécile
cukierman and key et sénatrice pcf qui
sont en duplex avec nous elle vous
parleront notamment du monde d'après les
enseignements qu'on peut tirer de cette
crise du corps ou d'un virus
avant de conclure avec yves thréard qui
est directeur adjoint éditorialiste du
figaro qui aura son regard à lui sur
tout ce que vous aurez 10 les trois
quarts d'heure précédent première
question on est dans la troisième
semaine de déconfinement est ce que vous
diriez pour l'instant que tout va bien
en tout cas tout va mieux ce qui est
certain c'est que aujourd'hui le
confinement porte des résultats les
français l'ont respecté et que donc les
premiers jours de déconfinement se passe
plutôt bien c'est encourageant non il
faut attendre encore une dizaine de
jours pour être sûr qu'on est qu'on
évite une deuxième vague qui est tant
redoutée par beaucoup de françaises et
de beaucoup de visites les français se
comportent bien c'est un satisfecit
aussi pour le gouvernement
non mais vous savez c'est pas c'est un
gouvernement qui ait à recevoir les
lauriers c'est pas une question de
laurier moi je suis pas là dedans je
suis pas dans la politique politicienne
la situation est trop grave l'axis crise
sanitaire est trop peu inquiétante pour
qu'on fasse de la tambouille
politicienne
tant mieux si le découvriront se passe
bien vous savez on souhaite tous chez
les républicains comme chez tous les
français que le déconfinement se passe
au mieux qu'on évite tout sauf leur
confinement parce qu'il faut éviter leur
confinement
il faut éviter cette deuxième vague
aujourd'hui on a des bons indicateurs
maintenant il mérite d'être confirmé
attendre une dizaine de jours quinze
jours pour être
de cette tendance vous disiez tout de
suite bon on peut craindre une deuxième
vague est ce qu'il n'ya pas une autre
crainte qui est celle d'une crise
économique voir de tensions sociales
si bien entendu et elle ne me sentais
venir ça oui on la sent venir très
fortement je suis dans un département de
l'ain qu'un département industriel et on
sent bien la difficulté de la relance
économique
la difficulté pour les entreprises qui
vont tout sortir du chômage partiel et
qui donc était sous oxygène jusqu'à
maintenant ils vont se retrouver face à
la réalité économique et la réalité
économique ça va être peut-être pour eux
une baisse de chiffre d'affaires divisé
par deux et du chauffage et du chômage
et des commandes en moins on le voit
malheureusement avec l'exemple
d'actualité de renault donc c'est très
inquiétant c'est pour ça qu'il faut agir
vite et fort et que nous plaidons pour
un plan de relance dès l'été avant l'été
et pas au mois de septembre comme le miz
économies l'annoncé
on va accueillir maintenant brigitte
boucher de la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale
on soit brigitte françois francis
bonsoir damien abad
bonsoir alors on voulait parler du ségur
de la santé qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui
edouard philippe a déjà pris la parole
pour dire qu'il y aurait des hausses
significatives sur les salaires est ce
que c'est bien la priorité pour vous la
revalorisation salariale est
indispensable elle doit être structurant
c'est pas la renégociation salariale
c'est pas simplement des primes ça doit
être une augmentation des salaires sur
la durée nous plaidons pour une loi de
programmation sanitaires sur cinq ans
qui vise à ce qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy
c'est à dire une augmentation de 5% par
an des salaires d'aisance et des
soignants sur les cinq prochaines années
ça c'est une priorité mais ce ne serait
pas suffisant il ya aussi d'autres
débats 500 par an pour avoir une idée on
voit martin hirsch qui dit il faut une
hausse de 25% ça correspond à 250 euros
c'est à peu près cet ordre de prix là
puisque 5 % 16 correspond à combien pour
vous tout dépend tout dépend du niveau
de salaire de 2 chaque infirmier de
chaque personnage aura beaucoup ça sur
cinq ans a fait 25 % 25 % c'est ce qu'on
a fait sur la lancée par an c'est ce
qu'on a fait sur l'allocation adulte
handicapé et c'est ce qu'elle ait fait
nicolas sarkozy et je pense ça a porté
ses fruits
pourquoi parce que si on se contente
d'une prime ça ne suffira pas et donc il
nous faut revoir la politique ça il faut
aussi dire la vérité aux français c'est
pas ça pourra pas tous être financés par
le budget de l'état et pas tous être
financées par les finances publiques qui
sont déjà en grande difficulté à
l'hôpital oui bien financée par kiel
alors falloir eh bien il va falloir
travailler justement à des partenariats
public privé il va falloir travailler à
des imbrications entre public et privé
beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus conséquente pour qu'à
nouveau l'hôpital public deviennent
attractifs et qu'un nouveau on puisse
attirer des médecins hospitaliers bien
rémunérés mais aussi de grande qualité
petite précision ça veut dire des
hôpitaux et des cliniques qui pourraient
fusionner peut-être pas fusionner mais
en tout cas il faut inventer ces
complémentarités c'est à dire c'est à
dire approché cliniques et hôpitaux
faudra il faudra travailler à ce
rapprochement
pourquoi parce que regarder ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui regardons la réalité
on a eu par moments des cliniques
privées qui était vide dans secteur
certains secteurs du territoire et des
patients qu'on a transféré dans un
hôpital public à un autre je pense que
là aussi l'imbrication entre le public
et le privé elle doit être posée est mis
sur la table en tout cas ça doit être le
rôle de la droite que de la mettre sur
la table alors le gouvernement avance
déjà quelques pistes et notamment
olivier ferrand qui veut remettre en
cause les 35
à l'hôpital est ce que c'est une piste
que vous appuyez oui depuis le début moi
je suis de ceux qui disent que les 35
heures ont détruit l'hôpital public il
faut ne pas avoir peur de le dire parce
que j'ai ressenti le milieu de la santé
un peu sur leur trait là dessus hésitant
en disant mais non finalement c'est pas
tout à fait cela moi je pense
fondamentalement qu'il faut mettre la
question du temps de travail au coeur du
débat au coeur d'un excellent moyen de
contourner un peu les augmentations de
dire travailler plus pour gagner plus
mais pas d'augmentation slogan
exactement et jeux de chez vous de
nicolas sarkozy mais est-ce que c'est
pas un moyen de contourner tout
simplement les augmentations de salaire
sur un le même temps de travail non je
ne crois pas je crois qu'on peut mener
les deux et que même ce sera nécessaire
de mener les deux mais ce serait mentir
aux personnels soignants ou d'infirmer
que de leur dire uniquement on va
augmenter votre salaire sans effort et
fort en tant que tel moi je pense
fondamentalement vous savez d'abord les
35 heures ont nettement quand vous étiez
infirmiers au front où vous n'avez pas
vu les 35 heures et c'est ça mais vous
avez vu l'épuisement des personnels et
on a vu les puits demandé alors comment
on fait parce que et pourquoi il ya un
épuisement pas parce qu'ils ont
travaillé un peu plus que 35 heures mais
parce qu'il ya une si quand même
aussi quand même mais parce qu'il ya une
désorganisation parce qu'il ya une
souffrance au travail parce qu'il n'a
pas les moyens suffisants
sandra des indices de commentaire en
tout cas il faut et moi je les dis
depuis longtemps mais il faut
sanctuariser la fonction publique
hospitalière
il faut que la fonction publique
hospitalière échappe à toute logique
comptable et à toutes les objections
qu'on a été viré curieux et vito pas de
fermeture des services une offre au
moratoire
il nous faut un jeune et un moratoire
sur les fermetures de lits sur les
fermetures d'hôpitaux et sur la question
effectivement de la diminution des
effectifs hospitaliers
c'est fondamental pourquoi parce qu'il
faut d'abord retrouver de la confiance
et retrouver de la confiance
ça nécessite de démarrer avec ses
présupposés là alors vous devriez
légiférer d'ici deux mois
puisque le temps de la concertation il
faudra à peu près cette semaine
est-ce qu'on peut refaire tout le
système de santé d'ici deux mois
non bien sûr que non mais il y à des
urgences
le constat on l'a le diagnostic tout le
monde le connaît la réalité c'est qu'il
faut une volonté politique et les moyens
d'arriver à cette volonté à cette
ambition politique
donc on peut agir fit mais agir vite et
agir sur la durée ce n'est pas
antinomique
il nous faut pas un énième plan hôpital
gouvernement a déjà présenté plusieurs
on a vu quels résultats il nous faut
changer totalement logique des choses
vous ne pourrez pas réformé l'hôpital
public français si dans le même temps
vous renforcez pas par exemple la
médecine de ville
si vous défendez pas les hôpitaux de
proximité et tout ceci c'est un tout
c'est un ensemble global
donc c'est pour ça que nous plaidons et
nous déposerons d'ailleurs dans une
niche une mode programmation sanitaire
qui vise justement à ce qu' on puisse
engager sur les cinq prochaines années
ce que serait la réforme de l'hôpital en
france
c'est ça qu'il nous faut faire ça
nécessite beaucoup d'investissements en
tout cas vous êtes d'accord pour dire
que les difficultés ne datent pas
d'aujourd'hui ce matin françois hollande
ancien président la république sur
france inter a eu cette petite phrase
alors d'abord j'ai présidé la france
pendant cinq ans donc j'ai ma part de
responsabilité aussi dans la situation
de l'hôpital j'avais fait en sorte sous
sous sous la présidence de d'améliorer
les parcours professionnels de valoriser
un certain nombre de catégories aides
soignantes ou infirmières mais ça ne
suffit pas j'ai ma part de
responsabilité vient de dire françois
hollande
vous étiez aussi au pouvoir avant à vous
personnellement mais la droite est ce
que finalement il ya une part de
responsabilité aussi de la part de la
droite mais bien sûr qu'il ya une
responsabilité partagée et collectives
et bien sûr qu'on doit tous en tirer les
conséquences et le siège que la droite
n'a pas bien fait et vous savez il
faudra poser par exemple la question de
la tarification à l'activité
elle était peut-être nécessaire à
d'autres certainement remodeler la
question des agences régionales de santé
aujourd'hui on doit les refonder à c'est
la droite qui lynchent heures les
refonder il faut les supprimer
peut-être pas les supprimer moi je pense
qu'on peut peut-être améliorer leur
fonctionnement avec davantage de
présence d'élus notamment départementaux
régionaux et une réflexion à avoir
ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que le
monstre bureaucratique qui est devenu
l'hôpital public français doit changer
la donne à cause de la droite non partez
vous avez le coût pour les tarifications
l'activité mais vous savez il ya deux
manières de faire la politique
soit vous accuser les autres en
permanence et vous dites que vous n'y
êtes pour rien et que vous êtes
responsable de rien et que tout ce que
vous avez fait est merveilleux et alors
les français ou tourner le dos sauf
assumer une part de responsabilité
collective
je dis simplement quand même qu'il ya un
point sur lequel on ne pourra pas nous
attaquer c'est sur la question des
stocks de masques
on y reviendra t certainement sur ce
sujet là et sur la gestion de la crise à
chaîne la droite n'a absolument rien à
se reprocher mais par contre nous devons
ensemble regarder les choses en face et
si on ne regarde pas cette réalité en
face comment voulez vous trouver les
bonnes solutions il faut le dire ils
assumer en tant que alors le 3 juin à
l'assemblée nationale sera débattu une
proposition de loi de la république en
marche sur le don de congé aux soignants
qui seront converties en chèques
vacances
est-ce que vous voterez cette
proposition la vôtre a d'autant plus que
c'est nous qui l'avions proposé il ya un
peu une manie à celle a réduit quand
marché de piquer les idées des autres
et d'expliquer que c'est finalement le
leur on a eu le même débat d'ailleurs
avec avec maximino l'un de nos députés
chez nous qui avait fait aussi une
proposition de loi pour permettre le don
de congés qu'on puisse octroyer aux
soignants non oui bien sûr qu'un nous la
voterons et de nous le soutiendrons dota
plus c'était une de nos idées alors il
ya un autre vote qui nous intéresse
c'est le débat et le vote sur ce top cow
vite vous savez cette application qui
permettra de tracer les personnes qui
ont été en contact avec un malade udu
coronavirus le débat et le vote auront
lieu mercredi est ce que là aussi vous
allez voter pour nous en débattrons
demain en rayon de groupe on aura une
réunion go place ce thème en partie
déterminée ça coince non non c'est pas
que ça coince c'est que vous savez nous
on est vous avez remarqué mais un groupe
dans lequel on débat dans lequel on peut
s'exprimer librement
et on n'est pas dans un ton martial ça
change un peu du groupe larry vu qu'un
marche bien le reconnaître très
volontiers mais la différence c'est que
nous les gens ils partent pas il reste
parce que justement ils ont cette
liberté qui sont donc on aura ce débat
et à l'issue de ce débat donc à l'étude
et ryland group
on prendra une position de groupe mais
ce que je peux vous dire ce soir c'est
nous avons beaucoup de réserve beaucoup
de réserve à la fois sur le plan des
libertés publiques mais aussi sur la
question de l'efficacité du dispositif
j'ai entendu comme vous qu'il fallait
que 60% de la population
télécharger cette application pour que
ce dispositif est une efficacité je
m'interroge est-ce que les français vont
télécharger sa massivement je
m'interroge aussi quand vous du
caractère anonyme et volontaire de toute
cette de tous cette application dont
nous avons beaucoup de questions
beaucoup d'interviews six jours
rang on va plutôt soit vers le vote
contre soit vers l'abstention
écoutez pas le vote pour terminera
demain dans le vent pour en tout cas je
vous confirme que l'orientation est
plutôt celle là mais c'est l'abstention
ça sera certainement dans ce cadre là on
pas pour en tout cas
a priori non mais bon ces deux votes la
masquer des divisions quand même on l'a
vu déjà sur le déconfinement avec un
groupe qui peut s'éclater en trois
groupes pour contre abstention est ce
que c'est pas un peu la même chose
est-ce que ça masque pas des divergences
de points de vue je ne crois pas vous
savez le groupe l'est républicain n'est
pas divisée il est libre et c'est une
grande chance d'être libre par contre
soyons très clairs
nous voulons une convergence sur un vote
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quand
vous êtes 104 députés vous avez 70 80
députés qui votent la même chose vous
avez une position majoritaire qui est il
a clairement assumé
ensuite vous avez dix ou quinze qui
parce que pour des conditions
différentes et en plus on est sur un
sujet majeur qu'un sujet des libertés et
sur les libertés on a toujours respecté
cela je pense que c'est une richesse
mais vous verrez peut-être que vous
aurez en plus une agréable surprise
mercredi dans le vote convergent des
députés républicains
alors maintenant on va parler d'autre
chose parce que des commissions d
enquête sur le corps d'un virus qui sont
dans l'air aussi à la commission d'
enquête sur la gestion de la crise du
coc vite 19 une commission denquête va
débuter au sénat fin juin quand
souhaitez-vous qu'elle ait lieu à
l'assemblée nationale le plus rapidement
possible d'abord parce que moi je
l'avais demandé pour le mois de
septembre
parce que je considérais qui avait le
temps de la crise tv le temps de la
reconstruction économique et ensuite le
temps de l'analyse des leçons à tirer
mais comme le sénat lancé travaux dans
la division alors que l'assemblée le
sénat pas du tout c'est que comme le
sénat lance ses travaux des enquêtes ce
qui est tout à fait normal et comme et
encore une fois il faut confirmer dans
les dix prochains jours
nous sommes dans une phase de
déconfinement il nous semble légitime
d'avoir une concordance de calendrier
donc dès demain
le président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand présentera donc les
rapports d'observations sur la mission
d'information qui s'est tenu jusqu'à
maintenant il va rendre des conclusions
de cette mission d'insertion et moi je
demanderais à ce que dès demain
cette mission d'observation et
d'information se transforme en
commission une enquête de manière à ce
qu'elle puisse s'installer dès le moi de
vous allez faire une démarche officielle
dans ce sens oui tout à fait
je ferai une démarche officielle dès
demain pour demander au président de
l'assemblée nationale que la mission
d'information se transforment et se dote
de pouvoirs des requêtes afin que dès la
semaine suivante on puisse installer la
commission d'un dernière question régis
déjà ce serait un rapporteur les
républicains pour cette commission
denquête est-ce que vous souhaitez être
sera porteur écoutez on verra c'est cela
aussi c'est une décision que je dois
partager avec mon groupe c'est de
l'ordre du possible
et est ce que richard ferrand peut
présider cette commission denquête c'est
à lui de dire c'est à lui de le dire
vous savez ce que vous le souhaitez
c'est moi je
il faut qu'on soit bien clair ce que
j'ai demandé c'est plusieurs choses
d'abord un con et un seul rapporteur
général est que ce rapporteur général
ils appartiennent à l'opposition ça
c'est important deuxièmement qu'on est
des vrais pouvoirs d enquête
troisièmement qu'il ya un équilibre et
c'est normal que la majorité et la
présidence si nous nous avons leur est
pas en général j'ai pas choisir en
payent le président de l'assemblée
nationale
mais peut-être que c'est mieux si ce
n'est pas lui mais je le dis très
clairement c'est l'heure pour décision
c'est le roman que vous avez le
rapporteur général qui vient de chez
vous merci brigitte francis mer fois on
va faire un petit détour par le figaro
live maintenant nous attend face en
rompant soir vincent non sans avoir rien
et tout ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis aussi sur le site figaro
live alors quel est le thème qui est le
plus débattu en ce moment parmi les
thèmes les plus débattus alors parmi les
thèmes les plus les plus débattus les
plus commentés sur le site du figaro
francis on retrouve ne bien sûr la
polémique autour des accusations de la
chanteuse camélia jordana samedi soir
sur le plateau d'on n'est pas couché je
ne suis pas en sécurité
face à un flic il y à des hommes et des
femmes qui se font massacrer
quotidiennement en france pour nulle
autre raison que la couleur de peau ce
sont notamment ces propos polémiques et
qui ont fait beaucoup réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui sont encore très
commenté sur le site du figaro commenté
aussi cet après midi la nouvelle
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner qui a été défiée par
la chanteuse la liberté du débat public
n'est pas de dire n'importe quoi a dit
le ministre de l'intérieur alors pour
autant il refuse d'engager des
poursuites
certains par rapport à ses déclarations
et à cette position déplore que le
ministre de l'intérieur ne respecte pas
assez à leur goût la liberté
d'expression d'autres déplorent qu'il
n'engage pas des poursuites
et vous qu'en pensez-vous damien abad je
pense que ça mériterait d'engager des
poursuites
je trouve que on peut pas tout dire et
je trouve particulièrement inadmissible
et assez ignoble finalement les propos
qui ont été tenus à l'égard de la police
en france
vous savez les policiers aujourd'hui en
france il souffre beaucoup depuis
longtemps avec les tensions sociales
qu'il ya eues avec les crispations qui
lie à la société et donc quand on est
ministre l'intérieur on doit protéger en
est le premier flic de france et donc on
doit protéger aussi et d'abord et avant
tout la police mais quand camilla
jordana dit qu'elle ressent ça comme ça
et que d'autres sans ça comme ça c'est
du ressenti c'est même peut-être du vécu
est-ce qu'elle a droit de le dire elle a
le droit de parler de son ressenti de
son vécu ce qu'elle a fait oui mais sauf
que à un moment donné quand vous créez
d'un ressenti personnel une situation
générale c'est là où ça pose problème
c'est de considérer finalement que parce
que elle a vécu ça c'est quelque chose
de systématique quelque chose d'organisé
est quelque chose de volontaire et c'est
là où ça ne va pas merci vincent da
écoutez ça va relancer le débat
probablement sur le figaro live merci
d'avoir été avec nous et maintenant
cette âme traduit de public sénat qui
arrive sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonsoir ta mère francine tout à l'heure
a terminé avec une commission denquête
il y en a une à la sonde nationale une
hausse aidé à sur le corner virus on va
repartir là dessus ce sont exactement
bonsoir damien abad a toujours pas que
ça mais problème plus loin c'est
néanmoins par la commission denquête est
ce que vous pensez vraiment alors qu'il
ya donc ces deux commissions d'enquêté
avoir voué bien les marges de manoeuvre
à l'assemblée on a vu notamment avec ce
président qui va être lrm est-ce que
vous n'aviez pas un petit peu d'aller
l'ère du sénat bruno retailleau qui pour
le coup pour avoir les coudées franches
on verra moi je pense que tout le monde
doit tirer les leçons de l'échec de la
commission d' enquête pénale à
l'assemblée nationale eh oui et
franchement ça a été mis en valeur ça a
été un fiasco pour la majorité et je
n'ai pas le sentiment qu'ils veulent
recommencer ce fiasco personne n'a
intérêt à recommencer cela donc nous
nous sommes dans une démarche positive
responsable déterminé parce que cette
commission denquête elle est absolument
indispensable et je souhaite que
l'assemblée nationale puisse aller au
bout de ses travaux dans la même logique
que le sénat est ce que vous allez
justement vos coordonnées avec vos
collègues du sénat aient l'air notamment
pour éviter les doublons pour que tout
ça puisse être complémentaires baisse
coordonner ces c'est difficile parce que
vous savez que les commissions d enquête
sont indépendantes que l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat en fonctionnement
indépendant mais ce qui est important
c'est en tout cas de pouvoir échanger
non mais vous coordonnez politiquement
entre vous en trouvez bien sûr parler
bien entendu bien entendu que l'objectif
pour nous c'est qu'on puisse ensemble
déterminé quoi à la fois les
dysfonctionnements les failles du
système la question des masques on l'a
évoqué mais il ya d'autres sujets qui
sont très sains par un tir groupé sur un
tir groupé un tir groupé en tout cas
nous sommes dans une logique de
complémentarité et de cohérence que ce
soit avec gérard larcher bruno
retailleau ou nous-mêmes à l'assemblée
nationale alors pour parler concrètement
de cette commission des requêtes qui
allez-vous auditionné en premier est ce
que vous aller auditionner agnès buzyn à
l'ex ministre de la santé elle fera
forcément partie des auditions
je ne sais pas si elle sera en premier
le calendrier aujourd'hui des auditions
n'est pas déterminée il faut réfléchir
aussi un peu à innover je crois dans la
forme dans la manière de mener cette
commission denquête j'ai un certain
nombre de propositions
mettre sur la table mais bien sûr qu
agnès buzyn comme d'autres seront au
d'innover dans la foi doit pas y avoir
de tabou en tant que tels que je voulais
faire sur la forme
vous verrez l'idée je pense aussi c'est
que on puisse je crois pas quand on doit
se satisfaire on se contentait
d'audition de ministres du gouvernement
si on veut comprendre l'importance est
cristallisée élargir veut aussi aller
sur le terrain et je veux aussi
rencontrer du personnel soignant qui ont
vécu la crise du coc vide au quotidien
je pense que ce leur remontée les
témoignages oui je pense que leurs
témoins et réclamé des pièces dans 90
des contrôles sur pièces elle peut avoir
des moyens d'investigation très
important et il y aura des pièces
essentielles a demandé comme les bons de
commande les bons de livraison sur les
masques aux autres etc
je pense que tous aient manqué de
justice quasiment justement non en tout
cas c'est pas ma volonté je ne suis pas
là pour faire un tribunal populaire que
les choses soient bien claires la
commission denquête c'est pour juger de
la responsabilité politique et non pas
de la responsabilité judiciaire il ya
une courbe du sud à réplique pour cela
et en aucun cas ma volonté celle la
responsabilité politique et aussi au
delà de ça les leçons à tirer parce que
les français attendent quoi de la
commission denquête ils veulent savoir
ils veulent connaître la vérité et
l'éventuelle mais ils veulent aussi
savoir comment on fait face à une
prochaine épidémie néanmoins parvenir à
agnès buzyn à ce que vous pourriez
l'entendre assez tôt est ce que vous
pourriez entendre avant les municipales
je souhaite pas le mélange des genres et
je ne souhaite pas mélanger les
élections municipales avec la commission
denquête donc plus tôt après c'est
quelque chose de trop sérieux
donc ça veut dire qu'on voit qu'il
s'avise n'est ce pas entendu après les
municipales parce que je pense que ça a
du sens à une logique vous savez si on
commence à faire la commission d'
enquête en interrogeant untel ou untel
candidats quelle que soit sa couleur
politique
on va on va décrédibiliser cette
commission denquête et le travail que
j'ai envie que nous fassions de manière
la plus intelligente la plus forte
possible parmi les autres ex ministre de
la santé ce que vous aller auditionner
les anciens ministres de droite comme
xavier bertrand roselyne bachelot à ce
qu'ils font aussi partie de votre liste
la question des masques la question de
l'hôpital c'était sur la responsabilité
sur et aucun tabou à cela d'ailleurs
xavier bertrand lui-même m'a dit qu'il
se tenait à disposition des commissions
d'enquêté qu'il était tout à fait ok
pour répondre être auditionné c'est
normal est d'ailleurs en montrera aussi
la manière dont ils ont géré la crise
qu'on lui a géré la crise par rapport à
marisol touraine par exemple
et ce sera l'occasion de faire des
retrouvailles aussi haut mais vous savez
on n'a pas besoin de la commission
denquête pour échanger à a
il revient au bercail non mais nous
avons toujours eu une très bonne
relation et c'est toujours le cas et et
il fait un travail comme président de
région absolument remarquable et c'est
important que dans notre famille
politique au sens large du terme on
puisse échanger comme avec valérie
pécresse comme eq laurent wauquiez ou
françois baroin c'est important qu'on
puisse avoir ce moment des valeurs on
parle de la crise sanitaire mais il ya
aussi la crise économique on l'évoqué
but alors au début d'émission la
situation économique bruno le maire donc
le ministre de l'économie a confirmé que
le chômage partiel soit sera moins pris
en charge par l'état à partir de lundi
prochain et sera plus prise en charge
par les entreprises à hauteur de 15%
est ce que vous vous demandez comme l'a
demandé le medef doit de rester au
dispositif actuel
je crois que on ne peut pas rester
indéfiniment dans le chômage partiel et
tout le monde l'a bien compris
ce dispositif là il a permis de mettre
sous oxygène et respiration artificielle
des entreprises pendant un temps donné
maintenant on va en sortir
progressivement moi je souhaite
reprendre la proposition d'eric woerth
qui est de dire que on sort du chômage
partiel progressivement quand en partir
de quand elle à partir de la fin de juin
début juillet proposait le gouverneur
mais que par contre ce que nous
proposons c'est qu'en contrepartie cela
des allègements de charges
pourquoi pour permettre aux entreprises
de passer ce cap difficile parce que
quand vous allez avoir votre chiffre
d'affaires qui va être divisé par deux
ce cas là c'est que vous allez avoir le
même nombre de salariés est bien falloir
faire face à cela et si vous allez j'ai
pas les charges et bien il y aura des
licenciements également autres annonces
et bien 450 milliards d'euros ont été
débloqués par l'état depuis le début de
la crise
bruno le maire mise sur la croissance
pas sur les augmentations d'impôts pour
pouvoir relancer la machine est ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne stratégie nous
nous voulons zéro augmentation d'impôts
et nous verrons si le gouvernement
arrive à tenir ce cap là nous l'avons
dit depuis le début c'est une marque de
fabrique des républicains pas de hausse
d'impôt ni local ni nationale la
croissance vous y croyez ben en tout cas
il faudra aussi sur la croissance c'est
suffisant kyocera ensuite mais miser sur
la croissance bien entendu il faudra
surtout miser sur la capacité
d'innovation
nos chefs d'entreprise et la relance
économique mais permettez moi d'avoir
des sources d'inquiétude quand je vois
comment l'état veut conditionner ses
aides par exemple à renault ou
à air france permettez-moi de
m'interroger parce qu'aujourd'hui si
c'est pour distribuer des aides et dans
le même temps leur couper les ailes ça
va pas leur main je ne sont pas vraiment
conditionner les aides pour renault
bruno le maire ce matin justement à
propos de renault a dit qu'il n'exigeait
pas le maintien des sites en france
oui mais il ya d'autres conditions par
contre qui risque d'être posée notamment
le fait par exemple de plus produire des
voitures de grosses cylindrées comme les
renault scénic ou comme les renault
espace et autres je pense qu'il faut
qu'on ait une réflexion là dessus parce
qu'on peut pas casser la politique
industrielle de renault dans le même
temps qu'on lui distribuer des aides
surtout par les temps qui courent donc
jeudi sur la filière automobile et sur
la filière aéronautique qui sont deux
fleurons industriels français
il ya fort que le gouvernement est un
discours clair de défense de nos
entreprises émergentes avec des
contreparties quand on voit les plans
sociaux qui sont en train de se préparer
alors qu'il ya quand même 5 milliards de
parler la contrepartie pour nous aller
sur l'emploi et uniquement sur l'emploi
alors c'est à dire que s'il ya des
césars ferme c'est pas grave non nous
dit si l'emploi est maintenu il faut que
les emplois demandés après y avoir des
mois je mon souhait c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas de site qui ferment notre souhait
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de site et que
l'emploi sont maintenues mais c'est pas
une condition sinequanone mais attendez
vous penser aujourd'hui que l'état
français sera en capacité sur le long
terme de dire arnaud vous n'avez pas le
droit de faire mais tel ou tel parce
qu'il est actionnaire et wimille
actionnaires dont il est très gros z 5
milliards de d'accord mais je pense très
concrètement que ce sont des si vous
voulez ce sont des promesses de papier
et que la réalité c'est quoi c'est la
commande
la réalité c'est le nombre de commandes
de voitures qu'il y aura c'est pour ça
que je disais qu'il faut pas des
conditions qui soient trop restrictive
notamment dans le développement de
voitures futur parce que sinon et bien à
un moment donné la concurrence intense
yen rattrapera tout ça donc j'attends de
voir mais en tout cas sur ce plan là
j'ai beaucoup de réserves aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'inquiétude parce que je vois
qu'on est encore dans le même temps et
que l'on en même temps en matière
économique là aussi mon travail à bâle
et les annonces du gouvernement sur son
plan automobile
autre sujet important en matière
économique bien sûr et bien les hôtels
les restaurants
jeudi on doit avoir et bien de nouvelles
annonces de l'exécutif sur ce sujet
est-ce que ses hôtels ses restaurants
goff pour vous ouvrir ou rouvrir au plus
vite
oui d'abord les hôtels n'ont jamais été
fermé mais sélection et cafés les
restaurants
ils doivent effectivement rouvrir au
plus vite
dès le 2 juin est ce que c'est possible
de le faire dans l'ensemble des zones
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas au moins
dans les départements versent est une
exigence d'une demande des républicains
depuis le début et surtout je le dis
aussi de le rouvrir pas dans des
conditions de protocole sanitaire y
réalise à 4 mètres carrés par les quatre
mètres carrés j'ai entendu qu'ils
étaient plutôt abandonné on verra enfin
quand vous allez au restaurant en
famille c'est juste un peu de bon sens
quand vous passez votre temps dans votre
appartement à mettre votre épouse vous
avez pas lui demander de manger à un
mètre de vous donc je pense qu'il faut
un peu de bon temps un peu un peu mais
un peu de bon sens un peu de cohérence
en tout cas il nous faut des conditions
sanitaires bien entendu tous les
restaurateurs l'ont compris mais il ya
urgence à ouvrir et urgent surtout à
relancer la machine économique de la
question d'une dernière question sur la
réouverture du puy du fou sur
intervention du président de la
république est ce que c'est pour vous
normal d'avoir fait bien une catégorie
particulière sur le puy du fou d'abord
sur l'intervention de philippe de
villiers en premier lieu et puis ensuite
on a bien vu quoi on a bien vu la
division qui avait entrepris un abus et
les prémices mais moi je soutienne
président la république sur ce sur ce
point là parce que je pense qu'il était
nécessaire il est nécessaire de réouvrir
le puy du fou
on le sait parce que sinon on va mettre
par terre toute une économie locale mais
aussi en tourisme en tant que telle la
saison touristique elle sera majeur pour
l'avenir de nos sites touristiques
partout en france et donc il faut un peu
de courage et un peu d'audace et vous
soulignez de même la cacophonie qu'il ya
eu au sein de l'exécutif entraîneur
philippe emmanuel macron oui très
clairement on voit bien qu'on a un
premier ministre qui est très prudent je
comprends il est dans son rôle mais vous
savez la prudence ne doit pas aboutir à
l'immobilisme et par moments j'ai le
sentiment que la prudence
elle peut évoluer en immobilisme et ça
m'inquiète ça m'inquiète parce que
aujourd'hui on voit bien que on risque
d'avoir beaucoup de difficultés
économiques beaucoup de tension sociale
notre pays qu'on va payer au prix cher
le confinement il était nécessaire ce
confinement
aujourd'hui si le déconfinement et
l'amélioration épidémique se poursuit
alors il faut accélérer le mouvement de
relance est ce qu'il n'ya pas quand même
contradiction à voir le puy du fou
rouvert alors que tous les festivals
d'été sont arrêtés et qu'il n'y en aura
aucun jeu n'y a pas deux poids deux
mesures non je pense pas parce que
chaque choisi le savez les festivals
notamment quand
vous avez des concerts notre etc vous
êtes quand même c'est très difficile
dans un concert d'organiser la
distanciation physique quand vous êtes
dans un parc
nous on a rouvert le parc des oiseaux
par exemple dans le département de l'ain
qui fait quand même
cent mille visiteurs par an donc avec
des mesures de distanciation
physiquement c'est ce que pour l'instant
c'est pas le puy du fou comment ils vont
s'organiser
oui mais est-ce qu'il faut qu'il donne
les garanties bien sûr alors bien
entendu puy du fou alors qu'elle aimait
à jardin apparaît qu'ils sont toujours
fermées ça vous mêmes à leurs jours moi
je suis pour les parcs et jardins à
paris ré ouvre mais je vous le dis très
clairement aussi je pense que la
distinction physique on peut plus
l'organiser dans des parcs où il ya de
la billetterie ou les choses que dans un
concert dans un festival dans une fête
de village riz c'est plus difficile
parce que forcément il ya une
promiscuité au parc des oiseaux vous
l'avez dit qui est je vous conseille
d'ailleurs de visiter par et pourquoi
pas merci dame
merci beaucoup francine alors maintenant
de passer la parole aux parlementaires
qui s'adresse au patron du groupe et
l'air de l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
deux parlementaires marie le bec député
des yvelines vice-présidente du groupe
la république en marge bon soir merci
d'être avec nous à distance et cécile
cukierman qui est sénatrice de la loi
porte parole du parti communiste bonsoir
aussi à vous merci d'être avec nous et
tout les deux veulent vous parlez des
hôpitaux parce qu'évidemment c'est la
question d'avenir
et la question qui est au centre des
enjeux en ce moment on va commencer par
cécile cukierman par ordre alphabétique
parce que le parti communiste a fait un
tour de france des hôpitaux et vous en
avez tiré quelques conclusions
oui bonjour crois effectivement mais
c'est la directive dans la première
partie de cette émission nous venons de
vivre
après cette crise qui n'est pas terminée
cette crise sanitaire de mesure et je
crois tout et tous l'importance de
l'hôpital public mais aussi ses
défaillances pendant ces organisations
que parfois même dans sa présence
territoriale je crois qu'en tout cas
l'on mesure peut-être plus encore
maintenant le besoin d'avoir des
hôpitaux efficace dans la proximité sur
tous les territoires de notre de notre
pays de notre république
nous avons d'ailleurs faire une
proposition de loi issue d'un tour de
france des hôpitaux où nous proposions
un moratoire notamment contre la
fermeture des hôpitaux et notamment
entre hôpitaux de proximité
peut-être d'ailleurs qu'il faudrait le
revoir parce que depuis maintenant un an
un certain nombre d'hôpitaux et de
services ont malheureusement fermé
pendant un certain nombre de
départements et je pense pour
interpeller le sua va être que nous
avons les mêmes exemples en commun dans
notre région auvergne ou vers le rhône
alpes un certain nombre d'hôpitaux et de
services qui ont dû fermer ces derniers
mois et je vous laisse poser votre
question non savoir qu'est ce que vous
pensiez de cette proposition et jusqu'où
vous seriez prêt à aller pour maintenir
un véritable service public hospitalier
sur tout notre territoire au concept
bon moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on ait
un gel ou un moratoire
la fermeture des hôpitaux mais aussi je
crois des lits de réanimation en tant
que tel je pense que les français ont
très mal vécu le la déclaration du
directeur régional de la rs du grand est
en pleine crise sanitaire d'ailleurs été
limogé oui d'ailleurs mai
je pense que là dessus on pourra se
retrouver mais je pense qu'il faudra
aller un poil plus loin sur la question
jeudi est à l'heure mais de la médecine
de ville
ces versions veut que nos hôpitaux de
proximité est une chance de survivre
dans le temps il faut vraiment les
arrimer à la médecine de ville
et si demain on a encore plus de déserts
médicaux encore moins de médecins
généralistes alors ça sera encore plus
dur pour ces hôpitaux de proximité de
survivre et donc il va falloir mener de
front j'ai envie de dire les deux en
même temps un sens pour construire pour
construire cela et ce service public de
proximité
marie le bec vous voulez aussi parlé des
hôpitaux parce que vous dites vous bon
c'est très bien ces propositions mais il
va peut-être falloir rendre des comptes
aussi un petit peu oui j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt damien abad notamment
sur la question de l'inventaire en
matière des hôpitaux et du coup j'ai un
petit peu élargi ma question sur ces
sujets qui porte sur la question de
l'hôpital j'ai bien entendu les
propositions ont été faites par le
groupe ait l'air mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup de frustration à entendre la
position du groupe sur une éventuelle
abstention ou rejet sur l'application et
stoppe qu'ovide un débat et une
tentative d'appropriation alors que
c'est ce sont des sujets que nous
partageons et sur lesquels nous pouvons
nous retrouver sur la question du doubs
pour les soignants et finalement
monsieur abad la question que je
voudrais vous poser c'est vous venez
d'un parti gaulliste vous venez d'un
parti qui a un historique
justement d'appel à l'unité nationale
est-ce que vous n'essayez pas sur ces
questions qui relèvent des hôpitaux
finalement qu'on devrait tous porter la
responsabilité de l'état de l'hôpital
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui la mise en
place des 35 heures qui a désorganiser
le fonctionnement des hôpitaux sur la
tarification à l'acte ya aussi
énormément contribué à cette
désorganisation essayer de se réunir et
de faire que la gestion de la crise des
hôpitaux ne sont plus un enjeu de
politique mais un enjeu d'unité
nationale particulièrement après à
écouter nous invite à réécouter la
première partie de l'émission puisque
j'ai dit effectivement très clairement
qu' il fallait
on se met tous autour de la table pour
poser les bonnes questions notamment sur
la question de la tarification à
l'activité sur la question de l'avenir
nos hôpitaux publics en tant que tel et
surtout sur la manière dont on peut y
remédier oui mais marié le bec se
pointait aussi du doigt votre position
attendue sur ce top cow vide où là il ya
des accords je vais venir
d'accord mais déjà sur sur la question
des hôpitaux moi je souhaite et le
groupe l'est républicain mettra des
propositions sur la table sur le
déconfinement on a déjà mis 50 sur la
table on en mettra d'autre sur la table
également sur l'avenir des hôpitaux sur
l'application stop qu'ovide je vous dis
moi j'ai deux difficultés avec cette
application
la première c'est sur la question des
libertés publiques je vois bien et
d'ailleurs la cnil l'a dit elle même
elle est partagée lalani un avis
globalement circonstancié sur lequel on
voit bien que et il ya des difficultés
est ce que le jeu en vaut la chandelle
sur le plan des libertés publiques je
n'en suis pas sûr et d'autant moins sûr
qu'on a installé les brigades sanitaire
de l'assurance maladie est ce que on
n'est pas dans un espèce de double
emploi
et puis surtout que moi j'ai des doutes
sur le fait que cette application là
soient prêtes aujourd'hui j'ai de
réelles doute sur ça et sur son
efficacité en tant que tel mais comme
harry de bec dit unité nationale sur la
santé qu'est ce que vous lui répondez et
mais l'unité nationale ça peut pas être
sur la santé un genre oui mais ça peut
pas être on met la poussière sous le
tapis
ça peut pas être on est tous d'accord et
circulez ya rien à voir ça peut pas être
donner un blanc seing au gouvernement
non l'unité nationale ça nécessite moi
je vous savez vous avez et je vous en
remercie d'avoir cité le fait que notre
parti des républicains est d'inspiration
gaullienne et je vous le confirme notre
volonté c'est quoi c'est de dire si on
arrive à dégager un certain nombre de
propositions et les mettre sur la table
alors nous on a toujours pris nos
responsabilités vous savez le groupe
l'est républicain a voté tous les
projets d'état d'urgence toutes les lois
les mesures d'urgence tous les lois
d'urgence ont été votées par le groupe
l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale par cette crise donc nos
responsabilités on sait les prendre
quand il faut les prendre
simplement il ya des chemins sur lequel
nous ne voulons pas les cécile cukierman
vous vouliez aussi remettre sur le tapis
en un petit peu parlé mais papa très
avant la question des 35 heures parce
que là il ya quand même un décalage
entre vous au pcf et damien abad des
républicains les 35 heures qui seraient
pour certains le québec qu'il faudrait
remettre en cause mais vous vous dites
c'est peut-être pas ça l'enjeu
écoutez je le remet sur le tapis je
crois que ça revient naturellement dans
le débat politique en tout cas pour la
question spital hier je crois que ce
serait un peu trop simple de résumer la
difficulté de l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui à celle des 35 heures mais
pour élargir parce qu'on sent bien que
cette question était question elle monte
sur demain dans l'ensemble des secteurs
de l'activité économique
alors que l'on nous annonce et et le
voit venir et on le voit sur nos
territoires notamment un certain nombre
de réductions d'emplois avoir de
fermetures de sites et la r énormément
d'inquiétude pour toutes les entreprises
de la sous-traitance qui sont nombreuses
et qui mal économiquement le territoire
la question c'est justement est ce que
l'on remet en cause les 35 heures alors
qu'il semblerait que dans ce que l'on me
dise
et justement il n'y a pas assez de
commandes il n'y a pas les moyens de
faire travailler trou où est ce que pour
le coup de cette sortie de crise nous
reposons pas la question du travail et
je pense qu'il faut remettre et compris
le sens de la valeur travail au coeur
des coquins de cette discussion mais
sans forcément remettre la question du
temps de travail parce que l'on se rend
bien compte en tout cas que pour
quelques mois encore c'est plutôt des
licenciements que l'on risque de vivre
plutôt qu'une surcharge de travail pour
celles et ceux qui pourront en
bénéficier dans quelques mois d'avoir
rapport à un emploi dans notre pays
très clairement il doit pas y avoir de
sujets tabous et la question du temps de
travail doit être mise sur la table sur
la question de l'hôpital public sur
l'hôpital public je suis de ceux qui
pensent que les 35 heures ont
effectivement mis à mal l'hôpital danser
vous avez des missions des 35 heures
globalement sur les 35 heures
globalement ce que je peux ce que nous
plaidons chez républicain c'est quoi
c'est pas le changement d'un cadre
national en disant il faut passer de 35
à 39 heures pour tout le monde au même
moment non ce que l'on plaide c'est la
souplesse et le pragmatisme c'est à dire
que ce que vous dites c'est vrai dans
certains secteurs il ya des cires
certains secteurs où on va avoir
beaucoup plus on recourt au chômage ou à
l'activité partielle ou les commandes
vont être moins forte et où donc le
travail sera moins important donc
s'améliorer c'est à 35 heures c'est
exactement mais il ya d'autres secteurs
dans lequel ceci est totalement faux il
ya des secteurs qui auront besoin
d'intensifier le travail qu'ils auront
besoin de relancer des commandes qui en
ont besoin
produire davantage notamment dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent et il
faut que la loi le permettent et donc
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'en un
cadre souple des négociations au niveau
de l'entreprise est d accord qu il soit
fait au niveau de l'entreprise entre
l'employeur et le salarié
pour permettre ce 4 je pose juste une
condition à ce cadre c'est que pour nous
travailler plus égale gagner plus il est
la valeur travail qui évoqué ccq carbone
mais vous avez peut-être pas la même
définition non mais c'est peut-être
mieux brest mais mais à la limite et
travailler oui ça on est on est on est
effectivement totalement d'accord là
dessus mais la seule limite que je mets
c'est que je ne veux pas de 37 heures
payées 35
je veux pas que le travail est plus ça
entraîne un appauvrissement des salariés
et ça il faut effectivement que ça soit
aussi une revalorisation pouvoir d'achat
mais donnons cette souplesse et ce cadre
que les entreprises françaises appellent
de leurs voeux qu'est ce que vous
répondez à dernier à batz et c'est que
kerman là dessus vous a convaincu mais
il y a la question n'est pas de remettre
en cause de façon définitive ou pas
d'eau que bien évidemment mais il y
avait besoin en fait par étapes dialogue
social dans le pays mais je crois qu'on
doit être d'accord qu'il n'a pas eu lieu
et on lève malheureusement sur des
tacles précédent la question aujourd'hui
c'est de remettre certainement beaucoup
de choses à plat la question du temps de
travail qui doit rester protectrice pour
celles et ceux qui travaillent et puis
plus largement sur la répartition des
richesses parce que j'entends ce que dit
derrière bad sur la nécessité
d'intensifier quand certaines
entreprises du secteur dans certains
secteurs d'activité le le travail mais
pour intensifier on peut aussi embauché
on peut aussi développer d'autres façons
que simplement rajouter des heures
supplémentaires et encore heureux que
vous partagez l'idée que coiffe au
travail on a crié alors damien abad
juste sur le est-ce qu'on peut pas
embaucher plutôt que de faire travailler
plus ceux qui sont déjà en poste
mais ça c'est une fausse idée que la
gauche a toujours eu que croire que
parce qu'on a et faire de la réduction
du temps de travail on a créé des
emplois on a vu à quel point ça n'a pas
fonctionné c'est pas en divisant en plus
de parts le gâteau qu'on va enrichir les
personnes qui mangent le gâteau non
c'est en augmentant la taille du gâteau
et c'est ça c'est une différence majeure
moi je crois à la création de richesses
à la création d'activités l'embauchent
aujourd'hui honnêtement malheureusement
c'est pas ça va pas être au goût du jour
parce qu'il ya des inquiétudes parce
qu'il ya des instabilités sur les
is this man parce que l'investissement
public ralenti d'ailleurs je vous le dis
moi j'ai plaidé pour le deuxième tour
des municipales se tiennent au 28 juin
pourquoi pour d'abord pour une raison
économique 75% de l'investissement
public en france il vient des
collectivités locales si on veut
relancer la machine économique il faut
tout remettre en route et installer les
conseils municipaux et communautaires
alors quel avenir du modèle économique
marie le bec c'est là dessus que voulait
aussi interroger d'avis à battre parce
que vous avez entendu damien abad sur
les 35 heures qu'il voudrait modules et
vous vous dites faut peut être réfléchir
à autre chose je trouve que le débat est
celle cette crise sanitaire va nous
permettre effectivement d'aborder la
question de la relance économique sous
un angle différent quand j'écoute la
droite j'entends a effectivement la fin
des 35 heures ce sur quoi au demeurant
les différents gouvernements et
notamment la majorité a permis un
certain nombre d'assouplissements
j'entends aussi la suppression des
charges patronales et puis quand je les
écoute on va dire plutôt la gauche
j'entends le retour de la taxation le
partage du temps de travail
la remise en place de lignes h/f et je
crois aujourd'hui que cette crise
sanitaire elle nous impose également de
réfléchir à d'autres modèles de faire
d'autres propositions de travailler
aussi sur d'autres champs et on peut
notamment parlé de la question de
l'écologie tu as la transition
environnementale du rôle de l'union
européenne dans la mise en place d'une
souveraineté industrielle européenne je
crois que tous ses champs aujourd'hui
ils sont trop peu explorée par les
grands partis de droite de gauche
moi qui vous qu'on se saisissent de
cette opportunité pour débattre et donc
ma question que je voulais poser à
damien abad c'est finalement est ce que
les républicains ne sont pas toujours un
peu dans les mêmes vieilles recettes
moi je viens de ce parti politique je
suis dans une circonscription qui a très
longtemps voté pour ce parti politique
aujourd'hui je sens que nos concitoyens
sont aussi en attente d'autres choses
d'autres propositions en matière de
télétravail en matière du rôle social de
l'entreprise en matière de la question
environnementale et ça ne doit pas pour
autant remettre en cause toute l'année
la dynamique d'être activités que nous
avons mis en place depuis maintenant
presque trois ans pour attirer les
entreprises sur notre sol damien abad
vous savez vous nous ferez pas le coup à
nouveau du nouveau monde et l'ancien
amant de la réalité c'est qu'on a vu ce
que donnait le nouveau monde et c'est
parfois malheureusement pire que
l'ancien mende
non vous savez on peut être un parti
politique d'anciens en incarnant
l'esprit gaulliste que vous avez appelé
d'ailleurs de vos voeux tout à l'heure
incarner la modernité et proposer des
solutions nouvelles et les solutions
nouvelles
je crois qu'il faut pas nous caricaturer
la question des 35 le mans nous on n'a
pas de tabou et deuxièmement il faut
faire des choix
le problème de la république en marche
c'est qu'elle fait une pincée un peu de
celle de droite une pincée un peu de
poivre de gauche elle remue tout ça elle
met un peu de sauce verve et la
transition et la ballastière la sauce
faire la transition écologique justement
dîner mari de ma vie le problème c'est
que vous savez la politique c'est faire
n'y croyez pas mais c'est pas ça c'est
bien sûr j'y crois la transition
écologique mais on va être très clair si
la transition et géologiques ses maîtres
des parcs éoliens partout alors nom est
clairement les républicains avec julien
aubert et d'autre nous avons dit très
clairement c'est un scandale d'état
il faut dire la vérité la transition
écologique c'est pas simplement des mots
il faut que ce soit des actes dans la
réalité sur le photovoltaïque oui sur un
certain nombre d'énergies renouvelables
dit fort oui mais je crois pas par
exemple et là je pose la question marie
de weck
moi je nous nous pensons chez
républicain que la transition écologique
elle n'entraîne pas la sortie du
nucléaire
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
seule énergie décarbonée qui permet à
tous les français d'avoir un prix
d'électricité relativement bas et que
demain si vous voulez avoir les puits
les gilet jaune puissance 10 est bien
sortie du nucléaire et vous aurez une
explosion du prix d'expliciter vous
aurez des gens encore dans la rue et
donc là nous faisons un choix politique
qui très clair un choix énergétique qui
très clair mais voilà il faut pas
simplement brandir des mots et des
concepts
il faut surtout avoir des politiques et
des actes
marie le bec sur le nucléaire en un mot
sur le home ou sur le nucléaire et c'est
la politique qui est engagée par le
président c'est à la fois de dire le
nucléaire c'est ce qui fait notre
indépendance énergétique et c'est une
énergie qu'on doit savoir préserver
l'utiliser à juste et si on met avoir
une politique qui soit favorable
nucléaire n'empêche pas un rééquilibrage
énergétique
je crois pas qu'ils aient je ne suis pas
à titre personnel du tout une anti
nucléaire je crois qu'il faut qu'on
trouve un équilibre dans la position
qu'on défende
le sujet et que effectivement tant que
marin nucléaire qui est très fort et
très puissant on n'est pas incités à
travailler sur d'autres types d'énergie
il n'y a pas une énergie qui est
vertueuse au même titre que par exemple
sur l'autonomie il n'y a pas un type de
torture mais il faut pouvoir encourager
l'émergence de ce matin alors cécile
cukierman pour votre dernière question
parce que vous vouliez évoquez vous les
collectivités locales vous êtes
sénatrice donc évidemment ça vous tient
à coeur parce que vous dites que dans
cette crise elles ont retrouvé leur
place alors une question rapide et et et
une réponse rapide mais écoutez je sais
pas si elles ont retrouvé leur place en
tout cas aux yeux de l'organisation hôte
et réformer notre pays en tout cas elles
ont fait toute la démonstration de leur
efficacité est très certainement pour
revenir sur la question des masques si
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des communes
de notre pays les gens ont des masses
des masques gratuits d'ailleurs je tiens
à le souligner c'est parce que
effectivement les maires les présidents
de départements les présidents de région
pour la plupart se sont lancés dans
cette volonté de mettre à disposition
des masques pour tous les habitants
parce que c'était un enjeu de santé
publique donc effectivement une question
à damien abad sur eux je crois que là
aussi nous saurons dans les semaines
dans les mois qui viennent même si nous
ne découvrons pas tous à l'issue de
cette crise le besoin très certainement
de repenser l'organisation territoriale
de notre pays peut-être de la voir je ne
sais pas c'est qu'un rallye d'alsace
cadre renverser la pyramide et de la
faire partir des réalités locales que
vivent les femmes et les hommes tout
simplement dans nos collectivités
territoriales pour construire une
république dans laquelle chacune et
chacun se retrouve damien abad
oui je partage tout changer du sol au
plafond en tout cas très clairement mais
nous sommes nous sommes chez américain
d'aidé centralisateur et pas simplement
parce que nous avons beaucoup de maires
présidents département et président de
région de notre famille politique mais
parce que c'est une conviction profonde
et je crois hélas je partage ce que dit
notre sénatrice et que je crois
fondamentalement que ça doit être un des
chantiers de la préco vide cette
réflexion sur les collectivités
territoriales fait la preuve de leur
efficacité et c'est vrai moi je chantais
mairie faut leur donner plus de pouvoir
oui il faut leur donner plus de pouvoir
plus de compétences et surtout la
possibilité d'agir
en proximité prenons l'exemple de la
santé moi je souhaite que les
départements puissent s'occuper du mehdi
du médico-social et que les régions
puissent s'occuper du sanitaire avec un
cadre national bien entendu mais
regardons ce qui s'est passé sur les
masques c'est vrai les communes les
départements les régions ont pu acheter
des masques aux habitants les
entreprises également ont pu en donner
on a vu le poids de l'état donc il faut
redonner confiance aux collectivités
territoriales en ce pays
moi je crois qu'on est chaque frappe à
un nouvel acte de la décentralisation
mais alors remettons ensemble en cause
alors notre qui a fait beaucoup de mal
et qui a bouffé beaucoup de mal
notamment aux collectivités
territoriales et en particulier au
département séculière ackermann a l'air
d'accord avec vous sur ce point là en
tout cas marie le bec dernière question
rapide pour une réponse rapide vous
voulez pointé du doigt le rôle de
l'opposition pendant cette crise je
crois que il est impératif qu'on ait un
gouvernement un exécutif qui soit tenu
pour responsable de ses actes c'est ce
qui fait qu'on ait un décideur politique
qui est crédible mais vous allez avoir
le rapport de la commission denquête si
j'en crois vos propos enfin pas vous
personnellement mais en tout cas
l'opposition
comment est ce que vous vous situerez
pour être dans une attitude responsable
face à une crise donc aujourd'hui il
était effectivement très difficile
d'estimer les conséquences et par
rapport à l'attitude aussi de certains
membres de votre parti politique qui ont
par exemple fait le choix d'encourager
le recours à la chloroquine ou détriment
parfois de la santé d'alors sait comment
est ce que vous allez concilier
finalement bien sûr le rôle et le regard
vigilant de avoir l'opposition est en
même temps le rôle d'un grand parti
politique qui doit être d'abord juste
obtenir la chloroquine et après de
manière à gêner rapidement sur la
chloroquine très rapidement vous savez
moi j'ai des députés qui ont été soignés
la chloroquine ça a fonctionné pour des
députés de marseille notamment valérie
boyer ou guy teissier
je respecte leur choix moi j'ai toujours
dit je suis pas médecin je peux pas
juger d'efficacité de ce dispositif mais
force est de constater qu'il ya des
députés qui l'ont utilisé et pour
lesquels ça a fonctionné sur le rôle de
l'opposition en général
moi je vais vous l'avez vu la différence
nous ne sommes ni mélenchon ni le pen
nous sommes une opposition responsable
la seule opposition à l'assemblée
nationale qui ai mis des propositions
sur la table sur déconfinement la seule
opposition qui évoque t il
ensemble des textes d'urgence simplement
quand les choses vont bien on le dit
j'ai aucun problème avec ça mais quand
ça va mal il faut le dire aussi sur les
masques c'est un fiasco généralisée il
ya eu des injonctions contradictoires
il ya eu des erreurs des défaillances
des dysfonctionnements il faudra faire
la lumière sur ça mais je le dis sur le
rapport la commission denquête comme sur
les autres textes
nous aurons cette attitude nous sommes
en train de construire nous sommes un
parti de gouvernement et donc la droite
républicaine
elle doit incarner l'alternance
politique à emmanuel macron nous sommes
pas dans un concours de décibels entre
avec mélenchon et le pen
nous sommes dans un challenge de
crédibilité avec le pouvoir en place
voilà vous avez entendu d'amis abad qui
est qui a pris l engagement merci marie
le bec merci cécile cukierman d'avoir
été avec nous en direct ce soir dans
audition publique et m'attendent
accueille yves thréard
[Musique]
bonsoir yves françois francis bonsoir
vannes et laval ont soit vous n'avez pas
manier la langue de bois ce soir vous
avez directwrite on peut être ministre
et
maire d'une grande ville comme monsieur
gérald darmanin qui vient de regagner
ras qui vient de regagner oui puisque il
avait abandonné son fauteuil de maire de
tourcoing qui est une grande ville non
clairement non et encore moins quand on
empêche un député d'être maire d'une
ville de 500 habitants
on peut pas avoir le deux poids deux
mesures et moi je regrette cela seul
président république dit je me suis
trompé et je permis aux députés d'être
mère par exemple des communes de moins
de 2000 habitants et alors on voit
qu'une loi et on corrige ça ensemble
soit il considère que non il d'un
toujours la même logique du non cumul
des mandats est alors très clairement
cette situation là ne peut pas perdurer
alors vous demander la démission du
gouvernement de monsieur non mais quand
on est un choix au nom de quoi le miz
l'action publique des comptes publics
serait le seul en france à pouvoir est
dans une situation de cumul
quand on interdit à toutes les autres et
ce type devraient choisir en clair par
sas à lui de le dire
c'est sa responsabilité mais nous très
clairement on admet sa passe aux deux
poids deux mesures je vous garantis il
est insupportable aux yeux des citoyens
alors darmanin il vient gérald dardart
maintenant il vient de votre parti
c'était même une des figures de des
républicains il avait il a une idée
qu'il parce qu'il est de la droite
sociale il est un peu comme vous
d'ailleurs comme ça sur ce terrain c'est
celui de la participation tout le monde
cherche des idées pour et bien faire en
sorte que les salariés soient davantage
associés aux résultats
l'interassociation à l'intéressement
c'est une vieille idée de des années 60
d'ailleurs qu'il n'a jamais vraiment été
appliquée en france est ce que vous
seriez pour qu'on applique davantage
cette idée de l'intérêt comme vous
l'avez dit c'est une vieille idée
d'ailleurs que notre famille politique a
souvent porté comporte encore par voie
d'amendement très souvent qu'on a
défendu des gens comme nicolas forissier
dans deux groupes sont très allants sur
ce sujet l'arrêt oui on peut
certainement desserrer l'étau de la
participation permettre fluidifier
davantage les sommes versées que l'on
puisse jeudi avant un retour sur
investissement plus rapide
oui il ya certain nombre de verrous à
lever ça ne suffira pas c'est pas avec
ça qu'on va relancer le pouvoir d'achat
des français
mais c'est une piste intéressante c'est
une piste que nous avons toujours
défendu et que nous continuerons de donc
vous êtes d'accord avec gerald wallace
est plutôt gérald darmanin qui est
d'accord avec nous il ya une deuxième
piste d'ailleurs c'est l'impôt sur la
fortune qui a été en partie supprimée
par l'actuel
pouvoir exécutif il reste l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière est ce qu'il
faudrait pour permettre à l'immobilier
de d'émerger et bien de supprimer
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière je
suis pas sûr que ce soit un bon signal
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que ça c'est un postulat
plutôt une idée que de droite et cet
impôt sur la fortune oui et vous savez
moi je suis pas pour le retour du sf
donc j'assume clabaut la conviction de
devoir compte pas pour la suppression
des fils nus là où il ya un sujet
extraire a raison c'est que c'est
difficile et ni fait ni à faire parce
qu'en fait il ait accès celles et ceux
qui sont propriétaires immobiliers et
par contre ils sortaient de l'impôt des
spéculateurs
moi je pense l'inversé qu'il y avait une
réforme à faire de l'ifi notamment en
supprimerait la partie immobilière mais
la condition de sa du coup c'est qu' on
puisse la compenser par autre chose donc
certainement peut certainement sur les
organisations oui sur la spéculation en
bourse
oui il ya des élections municipales qui
vont approcher la bientôt le 28 juin
normalement c'est l'occasion pour la
droite de se refaire une santé
elles sont dans un contexte particulier
mais le premier tour a été bon pour la
droite
donc il faut que ce deuxième le perdant
de ce premier tour cette équipe c'est la
république en marche après des démarches
a très clairement les scores que vous
voyez sont souvent des secours en un
chiffre dans certaines villes enfin dans
des dents des niveaux qu'elle pourrait
donc et pourtant trois grandes villes
françaises et des républicains sont pas
en très bonne posture quand même écouter
ce que rachida dati peut gagner paris
oui c'est pas impossible ça nécessite
des discussions dans les arrondissements
ça nécessite en tout cas à nouveau de
relancer la machine et la campagne mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle a fait une
bonne campagne tout le monde le
reconnaît on peut avoir cette dynamique
a évolué la maison servant à marseille
avec monsieur goujon ça a évolué dans le
15e arrondissement dire que zemmour
doucement ça a bien évolué il ya un
accord qui a eu entre philippe goujon et
agnès evren l'accord il est sur la table
calais le 15e arrondissement le gagnera
faire un bon 10 par beau temps le 15e
édition ne suffira pas mais ce
rebondissement important
martine vassal n'est pas en très bonne
posture quand même à marseille je pense
que la gauche est unie pour le quizz
avec le renfort des écologistes récents
oui mais c'est un peu l'alliance de la
carpe et du lapin
elle est sortie en tête je pense qu'elle
peut gagner et nous avons de bons
espoirs pour que martine vassal gagne
mais ça nécessite aussi chez nous de
faire le rassemblement de faire l'union
de créer les conditions se dit en tout
cas c'est une excellente candidate elle
et elle a été très bonne présidente de
départements aussi des bouches du rhône
moi je la soutiens fermement
en plus ça aurait 40 pour un des partis
qu'on disait vieillot macho regardez
quand même sur les trois premières
villes de france
deux femmes et on est seul parti
politique à présenter deux femmes en
position de maire et à lyon c'est
impossible c'est parier ça fait à lyon
ce sera difficile mais vous savez je
mets la politique lyonnaise a parfois
ses complexités qu'on a du mal à voir
les compris parfois de paris donc les
jeux sont ouverts
est ce que le président de la république
doit changer de premier ministre après
avant l'été ça c'est au président de la
république de décider
moi je trouve que prémices c'est pas la
question de l'homme l'homme n'a pas
démérité vient d'ailleurs de votre parti
oui il a été au feu de l'action
là pas une partie facile et il n'a pas
démérité
oui parce que même si vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous étiez plutôt ses environs
maintenant est ce qui me gêne chez le
mile-end ans je trouve qu'il n'a pas
démérité il ya un point je trouve où il
ya une faiblesse c'est parfois ça manque
un peu d'audace et de courage il et je
sors je sens une prudence qui aboutit
parfois nous oui je comprends quand une
sa position mais voyez on attend aussi
un peu d'audace
on attend aussi qu'on a un peu de
courage elle était tellement eu l'audace
sa écouter pour au moins ne l'est pas
non plus très trop bu mais la réalité
c'est que moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est
quand même la détérioration des
relations entre prémices et priant la
république ces derniers temps ouais et
on l'a constaté à plusieurs reprises on
et ça ça ça peut poser un certain nombre
de difficultés
donc il faudrait qu'ils changent je suis
pas sûr qu'ils font honnêtement ce n'est
pas à nous de le dire pour nous peu
importe si c'est pour mettre quelqu'un
qui soit plus à gauche
bon voilà je vois pas comment il
pourrait se tourner vers vous bien sûr
ou non mais votre parti et non mais sur
votre corps on parle de sa vie et
bertrand est souvent cité savez ça
ferait un bon premier ministre
franchement je crois pas qu'ils aillent
bertrand sur de cet état d'esprit là
j'ai entendu vous avez vu comme moi qui
avais bertrand 1ère fois qu'il a
rencontré emmanuel mes baskets il était
masqué mais lui un signe de ses unes de
distanciation
en tout cas je crois qu'il a mis une
distanciation très clair les tigres oui
mais xavier bertrand il a trace son
chemin son sillon je crois pas que son
chemin se soucier de matignon je crois
que son chemin c'est la réélection dans
sa région et ensuite l'incarnation
éventuellement présidentielle ça donc ça
serait un bonheur
moi j'ai envie de dire vous savez
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
est quelqu'un et que ce quelqu'un ils
soient crédibles que ça soit xavier
bertrand ou françois baroin ou valérie
pas créé alors françois baroin vous
l'avez beaucoup critiqué parce qu'il
était aux abonnés absents
moi je sais pas moi qui les critiquaient
peut-être effectivement il était crédité
les critiques peut-être mais en tout cas
pas vraiment parce que vous savez il
faut vous a déçu la non non parce que
vous savez il doit aussi prendre de la
hauteur
très clairement il l'a dit bah on peut
prendre de la hauteur en acteur
silencieux ça c'est facile il est
président des maires de france y frère
en étant présent des maires de france il
a mis les mains dans le cambouis
il a été maire de troyes il s'est battu
pour les masques pour les tests pour
tous ces sujets là après vous savez
emmanuel macron les sorties combien de
temps un vent du bois de l'élection
présidentielle à peine douze mois avant
donc laissons le temps inférieur si vous
aviez à choisir entre françois baroin et
xavier bertrand pour mais je serai
lequel le meilleur je vous dirai pas ça
c'est pas pour faire de la langue de
bois pour sinon même leur parler mais
non mais d'abord parce que je suis prise
en groupe
et si j'ai été élu président de groupe
c'est parce que justement je
n'appartiens à aucune écurie et je veux
garantir cette protection je veux que
celles et ceux qui soutiennent xavier
bertrand comme celles et ceux qui
soutiennent françois baroin ils se
sentent bien dans notre groupe
parlementaire et qu'on puisse porter et
je vous l'avais pécresse vous avez dit
tout à l'heure
leyrit pécresse oui et bien sûr et je
souhaite simplement que celui ou celle
qu'ils soient le mieux placé on puisse
pousser des ailes et sur celle des
fossiles sont pas les leurs ils sont
plus à l est résorbée on a des
convictions connaître et partager ce
qu'a dit xavier bertrand
ce récemment sur la crise l'hôpital je
le partage pleinement et j'ai pas une
ligne a enlevé ce qui compte c'est qu'on
ait un candidat parce que ça et l'enjeu
pour nous c'est s'assurer d'avoir une
candidature entre la république en
hausse et seront un dernier mot petite
question des rejets estimés clair vous
avez le corpus idéologique où les idées
il vous manque une tête oui alors on
doit encore persévérer en tout cas on a
retrouvé je pense que l'on doit ou ne
doit vous disiez on n'a ni l'année le
retrouver mais bon je trouve qu'on a
retrouvé un cap
on a retrouvé une cohérence et on a
retrouvé une colonne vertébrale à faveur
de la crise mais depuis la réforme des
retraites et est donc en tout cas on n'a
pas fait de sortie de route comme on l'a
fait pendant la crise et gilet jaune et
ça c'est à mettre au crédit de la droite
maintenant il ya l'incarnation
politiques allaient majeur dans
l'élection présidentielle elles
viendront effectivement ce sera le gros
chantier pour la droite
merci yves et merci d'amiens
c'est la fin de l'audition publique pour
vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation de débattre avec aussi les
parlementaires qui étaient avec nous
tout à l'heure de répondre à nos
questions n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur figaro live
ainsi que sur les sites internet dès le
cp est tu peux public sénat audition
publique revient lundi dans 15 jours
parce que lundi prochain c'est le lundi
de la pentecôte
beaucoup ne travaillent pas ce lundi de
la pentecôte même si depuis jean pierre
raffarin
c'est un jour que le devons aller
collecter pour la feria de nîmes
malheureusement n'aura pas lieu c'est
alors merci en tout cas bonne soirée a
donc un jour
[Musique]